this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
breaking right now at four after a child
may have died after ingesting illegal
pills good afternoon thanks for joining
us at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas let's head right out
to david charns with the eight news now
i-team he's in the newsroom with more
david yeah christian and kirsten were
just learning that the victim here is a
15-year-old the i-team confirming that
this is just another case of fentanyl
pills being spread across our valley and
police right now in north las vegas
investigating several possible overdoses
at sedway middle school that is near
gowen in commerce involving several
children sources telling the eye team
one child has died after taking these
illegal pills and we had just confirmed
that child is 15 years old
of course these pills are just a tiny
substance of them this illicit fentanyl
can kill you and oftentimes people don't
know what is in them sources also
telling us that the clark county school
district is investigating all this and
we're also learning that the pills may
have been found at the school's soccer
field of course a lot of information
we're working to get more info for you
and we'll keep you posted throughout the
evening live in the newsroom i'm david
charns live local now